bienvenue à tous bonjour caroline
dangereux milices et parlement hebdo
votre rendez vous d'info du week-end
retour sur les temps forts qui ont
marqué la semaine politique avec tout
d'abord le débat en cours sur la réforme
de l'hôpital c'était le sujet de la
semaine au sénat avec des médecins dans
la rue au palais bourbon députés de
gauche et de droite ont cherché toute la
semaine un compromis sur la nouvelle
organisation de leurs travaux la gauche
a peur d'être lésés le président de
l'assemblée nationale bernard accoyer
tente de jouer les arbitres et puis nous
reviendrons aussi sur la campagne des
européennes qui peinent vous le savez a
suscité l'enthousiasmé
les derniers sondages les derniers
meetings ce sera dans cette émission
avec caroline leur égard le regard
forcément aiguisé de notre invité de la
semaine est notre invité cette semaine
c'est claude bartolone bonjour bonjour
vous êtes socialiste député et président
du conseil général de la
seine-saint-denis
pendant longtemps fidèle lieutenant de
laurent fabius vous avez repris votre
indépendance vous avez notamment aider
martine aubry a accédé au poste de
première secrétaire
aujourd'hui au sein du ps vous êtes
secrétaire national en charge des
relations extérieures
c'est exact aucune erreur et c'est donc
avec vous et sur ce 100 foot qu'on va
revisiter ensemble cette folle semaine
politique et parlementaire
on commence bien sûr avec la journée de
lundi et la campagne des européennes qui
se précise
en ce début de semaine donc les états
majors des partis politiques rentre
enfin dans le vif de la campagne des
européennes à moins d'un mois du vote le
7 juin prochain
les sondages placent l'ump en tête du
coup la gauche sa folle avec en toile de
fond un certain désintérêt c'est vrai
des français pour une campagne on a le
sentiment de ne pas vraiment parler
d'europe
tout de suite le point sur ces
européennes avec mathieu verlaine
cela ressemble à de l'indifférence
malgré les moyens déployés les français
ne s'intéressent que de loin aux
élections européennes selon un sondage
réalisé le mois dernier seulement 47%
des électeurs hexagonaux pense se
déplacer aux urnes l'ump à d'ailleurs
retardé a finalisé ses listes
elles n'ont été officialisée que jeudi
dernier c'est qu'elles ont donné lieu à
de délicats arbitrages le parti du
président en effet dû faire face aux
exigences de ses partenaires du nouveau
centre ou de la gauche moderne
à gauche on doit composer avec le
morcellement des forces
le parti socialiste joue des coudes avec
de multiples concurrents front de gauche
nouveau parti anticapitaliste écologiste
tous espèrent être les invités surprise
de ce scrutin
les socialistes auront donc certainement
beaucoup de mal à rééditer leur score de
enfin le modem espère se poser en force
capable de bousculer le dieu de tête
françois bayrou délaisse le traditionnel
message européen des centristes au
profit d'un vigoureux discours
d'opposition et rêve de retrouver
l'influencent de l'udf didier à cinq ans
pour l'heure selon les sondages l'ump
fait la course en tête avec 27% des
intentions de vote
faut-il d'ailleurs y voir un indice de
satisfaction de la politique de nicolas
sarkozy
le parti socialiste attend lui 23%
peinant à trouver ses marques
quant au modem il serait crédité de 10 à
14% des suffrages
verdict des urnes le 7 juin prochain
chris barton année sont étonnants ses
premiers sondages y encore quelques
semaines on disait cette élection
finalement c'est tout bon pour le ps et
une élection intermédiaire il ya la
crise on peut donc s'attendre très
vraisemblablement à votre sanction
que se passe-t-il au parti socialiste
qu'est ce qui se passe vous devriez
d'abord commencé plus tôt par le score
de droite parce que vous avez pu
constater même dans la présentation et
votre sujet qu'il n'y a qu'une seule
liste qui soutient le président de la
république et le gouvernement et ils
sont à moins de 30
qu'est ce qui se passe sur la droite
théoriquement à partir du moment où ils
sont les seuls à soutenir le
gouvernement il devrait être au moins à
50 % compte tenu du fait qu'ils sont la
majorité
ces derniers jours il faut quand même
que vous posez des questions mais jeunes
gens posent et d'ailleurs dans le sujet
c'était aborder la seule fois où le
parti socialiste a fait un score
exceptionnel deux fois il a eu
l'occasion de faire un score
exceptionnel une fois à la baisse une
fois la hausse une fois la baisse
c'était en 92 avec michel rocard vous
nous avions fait un score réduits parce
qu'il y avait eu la concurrence tapis et
là de la deuxième fois c'est en 2004
nous avons bénéficié il faut le
reconnaître
oui nous avons bénéficié il faut le
reconnaître de l'élimination hélas de
jospin au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle et nous avions gagné les
cantonales les régionales et les
européennes sur ce sentiment de il faut
voter utile on ne peut pas avoir de
nouveau un comportement électoral qui
puisse nous amener à connaître le 21
avril pour ce coup ci les sondages nous
donnent le score moyen du parti
socialiste à chaque élection européenne
je vous ai ramené un score qui est
important et je pense que il intéressera
vos téléspectateurs
françois hollande en 99 pourquoi je
donne cette nappe de cette date
c'était la période exceptionnelle du
gouvernement jones et lionel jospin et
il fait 21,9
alors qu'il y avait les radicaux et le
mdc sur la vie ce que j'en tire c'est
qu'actuellement pour un parti qui se
reconstruit qui a eu à remonter par
rapport aux images du concret tellement
loin que c'est déjà pas si mal d'être là
où vous
c'est un bon chiffre de départ c'est un
bon chiffre de départ nous sommes dans
une valeur dans une valeur qui est
supérieure à celle de 99 alors que c'est
une liste de socialistes purs jus et je
crois que c'est maintenant que la
campagne commence maintenant qu enfin la
droite à des candidats que chacun va
pouvoir se rendre compte du fait que les
socialistes ont leur liste complète
depuis des semaines qu'ils sont
rassemblés avec tous les autres partis
socialistes et sociaux démocrates dans
le cadre du manifesto et qu'ils veulent
maintenant présenter aux français des
propositions pour montrer que l'europe
rêver elle peut exister et elle ne peut
exister temps permettant au deuxième
groupe du parlement européen d'être
majoritaire c'est à dire en votant
social enthousiasme et optimisme de
départ
alors il y en a qu'on a compté un moment
parmi les indécis c'est bernard kouchner
qui aa brièvement laissé planer le doute
sur ses intentions de vote le ministre
des affaires étrangères a finalement
arrêté son choix il votera ump le 7 juin
prochain que mais son hésitation a créé
l'embarras au sein du parti de la
majorité
même si ces propos n'ont pas vraiment
surpris et michel barnier tête de liste
en île de france
il a dit qu'il avait besoin de lire les
projets je sais pas s'il a trouvé
d'autres projets à lire tout cas moi je
lui avais transmis celui de la majorité
présentielle qui est le projet de la
majorité pour changer l'europe que
l'europe soit plus protectrice et
qu'elles agissent plus et donc je suis
très heureux en liant ce document il y
eut trouvé des raisons de voter pour moi
bartolone bernard kouchner est il
toujours un ministre d'ouverture à
partir du moment où il soutient l'ump je
pense que il a franchi le rubicon depuis
pas mal de temps mais ce qui est
intéressant dans sa position c'est qu'il
est ministre des affaires étrangères il
aurait dû être le premier convaincu par
l'attitude de la france et du président
de la république au moment où la france
a exercé la présidence de l'union et
malgré ce bilan nous présente qu'on nous
présente comme un bilan extraordinaire
le ministre des affaires étrangères
hésite alors après pour le jack c'est
pas la première fois je vous rappelle
que en 92 il était sur la liste de
michel rocard et au moment des élections
il nous annonçait qu'il n'avait
voter pour la liste sur laquelle il
figure et j'ai l'impression que les
élections européennes ne réussissent pas
à bernard je la trouvais à lire michel
barnier savaient pas très bon s'il avait
trouvé autre chose à lire que le
programme de l'ump vous lui avait envoyé
je crois oui oui nous lui avons envoyés
par ce que il serait quand même temps
qu'ils s'intéressent quand même au bilan
de son gouvernement et aux propositions
que peut faire la droite parce que ça
fait quand même désordre quoi un
ministre important qui a du mal à
reconnaître qu'il est passé à droite et
qui a du mal à reconnaître les résultats
d'un gouvernement ça fait beaucoup juste
un mot sur l'ouverture des rumeurs
persistantes de claude allègre
claude allègre pardon qui entrerait au
gouvernement est-ce que l'ouverture
continue gens souhaitent du plaisir
moi j'ai vu ce qu'était d'avoir claude
allègre dans un gouvernement de gauche
et les réactions qu'il provoquait sur
les enseignantes de gauche et les
chercheurs dont comme un chant soit du
plaisir
pour le reste vous savez je pense que
nous n'avons plus à craindre de
l'ouverture dans la mesure où maintenant
ce gouvernement qui tarde à chaque fois
qu'elle se manifeste je pense qu'il ya
une stratégie du président de la
république et de vouloir faire croire
qu'il y a qu un seul projet à présenter
au pays et qu'il prend les meilleurs si
tenté que l'on puisse dire que claude
allègre fait partie des meilleurs mais
pour le reste maintenant il n'ya pas un
électeur sens et de gauche qui va
imaginer que ce gouvernement sarkozy
c'est gouvernement sarkozy fillon puisse
avoir le moindre label de gauche vous
avez pour un certain nombre de de ces
consciences de la gauche comme bernard
kouchner
vraiment c'est au moment où il y a eu
tout le débat sur les tests adn que je
me suis dit finalement ils sont
définitivement passé de l'autre côté
pour débarrasser sagres dit non non je
le regrette franchement surtout pour
bernard kouchner j'ai vraiment beaucoup
d'affection pour bernard il a un
parcours à la fois spectaculaires
médiatique mais sympathique et vraiment
ça m'a fait de la peine mais maintenant
il a vraiment choisi
je me considère comme un type
sympathique mais de droite et vous aurez
moins de peine pour claude allègre on
l'a bien compris elle remplace
maintenant est la journée de mardi la
fin du feuilleton hadopi à l'assemblée
mardi christine albanel respire enfin un
peu son projet de loi création et
internet destiné à limiter le piratage
des oeuvres est enfin adopté après vous
vous en souvenez sans doute de multiples
épisodes des députés socialistes cachés
derrière le rideau de l'hémicycle pour
renverser la majorité des chanteurs
comédiens et autres artistes de renom
mobilisé sur le sujet et au final un
vote au palais bourbon qui n'aura pas
vraiment mis fin au malaise tout de
suite le rappel des faits avec jérémy
hartmann résultats votants 557 suffrages
exprimés 529 majorité absolue 265 pour
296 contre 233 l'assemblée adopté un
vote exemplaires un vote massif c'est ce
que souhaitait jean françois copé le
chef de file ump peut être satisfait
cette fois ci le projet de loi contre le
piratage sur internet est bel et bien
adopté malgré un dernier baroud
d'honneur de l'opposition notre groupe
votera qu'on soit contre ce texte pour
trois raisons majeures
c'est un texte perdant perdant perdant
pour les artistes perdant pour les
internautes et même perdant pour un
cadre dirigeant de tf1
c'est un texte inefficace dépassée
inapplicable
c'est enfin un texte qui telle la ligne
maginot retarde stérilement
l'indispensable adaptation du droit
d'auteur à l'ère numérique argumentaire
20 la majorité a lavé l'affront cet
après-midi près d'un mois après le rejet
du texte par manque de députés ump dans
l'hémicycle qui est pour l'adopter des
contres le texte est rejeté
un joli coup pour la gauche un camouflet
pour la droite
aujourd'hui avec ce deuxième vote la
passe d'armes parlementaire est arrivé à
son terme
mais le groupe socialiste ne compte pas
en rester là il va saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
surtout l'opposition mise beaucoup sur
le parlement européen pour rendre
caduque cette loi hadopi mardi toujours
le très controversé projet de loi
bachelot sur l'hôpital arrive au sénat
largement retouchée par la commission
des affaires sociales la veille nicolas
sarkozy a tenté de déminer la situation
en faisant des concessions sur la
direction des hôpitaux notamment mais
apparemment ça n'a pas suffi à rassurer
les sénateurs de l'opposition fabrice
qu'une et je suis rentré tout et je suis
en train de vous répondre
et la réponse n'est visiblement pas du
goût de l'opposition non le gouvernement
ne lèvera pas la procédure d'urgence
malgré des amendements de dernière
minute au projet de loi hôpital
les sénateurs réclamé du temps pour
étudier les mesures annoncées hier par
nicolas sarkozy on voulait faire de
l'hôpital dans un service managériale et
finalement on va faire quelque chose
d'ambigu ni managérial ni médicale et ça
c'est jamais bon et par ailleurs bon jeu
comme sur les autres secteurs que ce
soit la médecine de ville ou ou a
fortiori la santé publique et les choses
sont bâclées principal ajout au texte
nicolas sarkozy souhaite que les
directeurs des chu soit entouré d'un
directoire
le très critique jean pierre raffarin
rentrer dans le rang et soutient le
gouvernement
il est clair que le président de la
république à redresser la barre nous
étions quelque peu dans une impasse et
les glaires que en rééquilibrant le
pouvoir avec une meilleure place donnée
aux médecins aux personnels de santé
le président de la république a fait les
gestes nécessaires pour que le débat
soit serein au sénat pour la sérénité
dans les débats on l'aura compris il
faudra attendre même constat dans la rue
le personnel hospitalier a maintenu sa
manifestation de jeudi nicolas sarkozy à
redresser la barre dès jean pierre
raffarin c'est vrai qu'il a lâché du
lest c'est ce que c'est suffisant je
n'ai pas l'impression d'autant plus
qu'au sénat les choses me paraissent
continue à être très complexe l'envoi
des amendements arrivée qui contredisent
les engagements pris par le président de
la république l'on a vraiment un
sentiment que sur une question aussi
importante que la santé l'hôpital public
voilà une réforme qui va plus inquiéter
les français qu'elle ne va les rassurer
dans la mesure où on n'y comprend plus
rien quel est l'objectif de l'hôpital
alors qu'est ce que vous proposez vous
pour réformer le pilote d'abord il
faudrait former il faut une réforme qui
puisse tenir compte des objectifs de
santé
je le vois par exemple sur la ph fait
les hôpitaux de paris je vois les
demandes qui existent et les besoins qui
existent notamment sur la partie
banlieue dans lequel est implanté
l'ap-hp comme la scène année et un
moment où
nous parle de vieillissement de la
population un moment où l'on nous dit
qu'il ya une partie des indicateurs de
santé qui se dégrade
on nous annonce 700 suppressions de
postes et je pense que c'est là où il
faut à la fois qu'il puisse y avoir une
réforme pour réussir à tenir compte des
déserts médicaux qui commencent à
apparaître en zone rurale en zone
urbaine pour réussir à voir des
importations qui permet de répondre aux
besoins de santé de la population et
qu'il ya une réforme qui montrent que
nous essayons de voir quels sont les
objectifs sanitaires que nous voulons
atteindre pour fixer les moyens qui
doivent lui être affectés dans les
classes la proposition qui est celle du
gouvernement malgré les interventions du
président de la république
on a l'impression de dire aux hôpitaux
voilà l'enveloppent qui vous est
attribué et débrouillez-vous et on a
l'impression que l'on dit à tout ce
petit monde l'on va mettre un directeur
qui n'aura pas tenir compte des
infirmiers des médecins du personnel
heureusement mais on avait le sentiment
que ce pauvre directeur comme si on
pouvait et dirigé un hôpital sans tenir
compte de tous ces personnels n'allait
avoir comme seul objectif que de tenir
l'enveloppent en plus avec ce sentiment
qu'il y avait plus de différence entre
public et privé sur les missions de
service public
l'on risque de voir apparaître des
hôpitaux privés qu'elle est plus encore
s'installer sur le côté du critt
lucratif de la santé et le secteur
public qui ne se verraient qu'avec les
charges lourdes ou sociales comme seule
mission ce qui ne correspond pas à un
objectif de santé acceptable pour un
pays comme le nôtre on continue sur le
mardi votre sujet revenir à une
actualité qui vous passionne puisque
c'est la vôtre le branle bas de combat
mardi rue de solférino chez vous dans
votre parti politique en retard dans les
sondages le ps de martine aubry n'a plus
une seule minute à perdre
il est temps de soigner l'argumentaire
est d'occuper le terrain les
explications tout de suite avec marie
brémaud branle bas de combat au ps les
élections européennes approchant à
grands pas les socialistes se remobilise
lui nous reste
cinq jours avant ces élections 25 jours
pour montrer leur qu'une autre europe
est possible une europe plus sociale et
solidaire belle unité affichée ce matin
au siège du parti afin de défendre leur
programme
en première ligne les parlementaires
leurs tâches convaincre par tous les
moyens les électeurs nous avons un
réseau d'élus qu'aucun parti n'a en
france dont il faut à la fois les aux
portes des entreprises des appartements
déposes dans la rue
et puis dans des courriers écouter faire
des réunions pas
c'est la seule manière programme
mobilise et mobilise également contre le
président de la république c'est sans
complexe que les socialistes affichent
l'adversaire à abattre tel est le vote
qui va être de plus en plus sarkozyste
c'est le vote qui va permettre de battre
la liste de nicolas sarkozy la seule
liste qui veut battre la liste de l'ump
ces listes socialistes un appel au vote
utile à trois semaines des élections ou
dans les sondages le ps reste à la
traîne avec 21% d'intentions de vote
contre 27 pour l'ump
je compte sur vous elles vous donneront
mais nous gagnerons on verra ça tout à
l'heure on va reparler de la campagne
des européennes mais d'abord on passe au
mercredi
oui la question du jour mercredi est la
suivante comment améliorer le partage
des profits jean philippe cotis ce le
directeur général de l'insee remet un
rapport sur le sujet à nicolas sarkozy
il fait le constat qu'en france la
progression des salaires est extrêmement
faible
de quoi relancer le débat sur la fameuse
règle des trois tiers que le président
de la république vous le savez peut-être
veut imposer aux chefs d'entreprise
récalcitrants tout de suite les
explications avec thomas carré pierre à
du rapport cotis ce syndicat et patronat
revienne sur tout le chapitre sur le
partage des profits
principal enseignement le montant des
dividendes versés aux actionnaires a
quasiment quintuplé en vingt ans la part
redistribuée aux salaires est en
croissance mais reste faible autour de
7%
pour de nombreux économistes il faut
donc augmenter le montant de l'épargné
salariale au travers des entreprises qui
réalisent des profits on peut augmenter
la part entre nîmes et variable des
salaires c'est-à-dire au travers de
l'intéressement de la participation aux
bénéfices de l'entreprise
et ça ça permet justement une meilleure
cohésion au sein de l'entreprise où le
salarié va pouvoir bénéficier également
des profits l'épargné salariale c'est le
levier que souhaite utiliser le medef
pour accroître les revenus des salariés
pour les syndicats en revanche il faut
augmenter les salaires dont la
croissance reste extrêmement faible
depuis 20 ans comme le montre le rapport
cotis ce qu'il faut augmenter le salaire
en tant que tel l'idée qu'on va
augmenter les entreprises et
mieux que les entreprises fassent des
profits et à ce moment là les
entreprises les salariés auront une part
tous ses profits sous forme
d'intéressement de l'epa salariale et
tout ça pour nous c'est une idée
totalement dangereuse totalement
infondées rôles et les partenaires
sociaux entameront des discussions sur
le partage des profits à partir du 27
mai le président de la république attend
leurs propositions avant le 15 juillet
si aucun accord n'a été trouvé à cette
date le gouvernement pourrait décider de
légiférer mercredi toujours après les
députés les sénateurs adopte
définitivement la loi hadopi avec une
position plutôt ambigüe des sénateurs
socialistes
après un vote favorable en première
lecture une abstention après les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire finalement ils n'ont pas
participé au vote en seconde lecture
hélène le vert le sénat a adopté
définitivement à 189 voix contre 14 et
en deux heures et demie à peine les
sénateurs ont adopté définitivement le
projet de loi hadopi le groupe
socialiste qui en première lecture
s'étaient prononcés en faveur du texte a
préféré ne pas prendre part au vote tout
en restant d'accord sur le fond nous
nous sommes
tenue en disant nous défendons le droit
d'auteur mais nous estimons que le
gouvernement ne met pas les moyens
suffisants pour la défense des droits
d'auteur voilà c'est clair exception
notable la voix de samia ghali sénatrice
socialiste des bouches du rhône pour qui
le texte ne répond pas aux enjeux posés
quand j'ai voté contre à titre personnel
donc un temps au nom du groupe et parce
que tout simplement je considère que
cette loi les obsolète et qu'elle est
inutile qu'elle est ringarde
après son rejet surprise à l'assemblée
nationale en avril la loi pourrait
rencontrer de nouvelles difficultés
cette fois au niveau européen le
parlement européen a adopté il ya une
semaine à peine un amendement qui
pourrait rendre l'application la loi
purement et simplement caduque
monsieur bodo et le parlement européen à
travers cet amendement ont lancé un scud
contre création et internet mais que ça
n'est pas la fin de la création internet
au contraire je pense que c'est une loi
qui doit se mettre en place rapidement
et la question que je pose aux
eurodéputés
c'est de savoir ce qu'ils en temps de
faire pour protéger la création en
europe
quant à la commissaire européenne aux
nouvelles technologies viviane reding ne
voyais pas ce matin de contradiction
entre l'amendement européen et la loi
hadopi alors le texte est passé comme
une lettre à la poste au sénat alors
qu'il ya eu on s'en souvient l'un des
débats houleux à l'assemblée nationale
est ce que vous comprenez le
comportement des sénateurs socialistes
qui ont hésité changé d'avis je le
comprends parce que ils ont placé leur
vote
après les décisions qui ont été prises à
bruxelles ils ont le sentiment que
finalement le texte qu'il aurait proposé
risque tellement de se retrouver
juridiquement en contradiction avec des
directives européennes qu'ils se disent
à quoi bon dans ce que dit la
commissaire européenne
oui j'ai l'impression que lorsque vous
reprenez les débats au sein du parlement
européen et notamment lorsque cet
amendement a été déposé la commissaire
européenne risquent de se retrouver à
affronter une une en minorité par
rapport au parlement européen et j'ai
l'impression que tout le monde reconnaît
le pouvoir qui a pris le parlement
européen donc je crois que c'est plutôt
comme ça juste un mot tout à l'heure
dans le sujet on parlait des socialistes
cachés derrière le rideau rouge enfin on
se moque de qui l'assemblée nationale
chacun sait que quand on voit le
fonctionnement de l'assemblée
pas mal de commentaires
mais j'ai l'impression j'ai l'impression
que c'était le truc trouvé par copé et
la direction du groupe ump pour faire
comprendre qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de députés ump qui ne sont pas
venus voter et je sais comment ça
fonctionne ça nous est arrivé dans le
passé au sein du groupe socialiste
lorsque une partie des députés ne sont
pas convaincus par un texte on a du mal
à les faire venir en séance et c'est ce
qui est surtout arriver quand on connaît
le fonctionnement de l'assemblée il ya
séduit sied il ya ces deux
collaborateurs de ministres pour se
rendre compte si un traquenard qui se
préparent ils ont même quelquefois dans
des lieux publics de l'assemblée pour
voir si il n'y a pas quelques
parlementaires en train de se rassembler
à la buvette ou dans les couloirs
donc il y avait un malaise des députés
de droite ont la revue d'ailleurs au
moment du vote définitif puisque bon
nombre d'entre eux se sont abstenus se
sont abstenus et c'est cela qui est à
l'origine de ce malaise et de ses
contradictions ou de ces votes
différents l'assemblée au sénat que
c'est quand même un texte qui a fait du
tort à la gauche avec un désaveu de
certains artistes de renom je ne crois
pas alors pour être clair je pense que
nous aurions dû travailler d'une manière
différente martine aubry a eu l'occasion
de rencontrer les artistes
il y a quelques jours pour refaire le
point avec eux et c'est vrai que au bout
du bout ce qui nous on reprocher c'est
que cette réunion n'ait pas eu lieu
avant la discussion de la loi hadopi
mais vraiment quand je vois les artistes
quand je vois le budget de la culture
lorsque je vois qu'actuellement ce
budget de la culture c'est budget pour
la culture sont plus portés par les
collectivités locales
dans une majorité sont de gauche s'il y
a des gens qui payent et vie c'est le
cas de le dire au propre et au figuré
pour montrer leur soutien la culture
c'est plutôt la gauche et je pense que
bientôt l'on verra que ce texte ne sert
à rien et qu'ils posent beaucoup de
difficultés en terme de liberté et
d'évolution des technologies affaire à
suivre en tout cas mercredi on reparle
aussi encore de votre famille politique
avec ce grand meeting socialiste
organisée à paris au cirque d'hiver
toujours en alerte après les mauvais
sondages de la semaine qui montre je
vous le rappelle un vrai retard pour les
socialistes le parti de martine aubry
affine sa stratégie et c'est peut-être
de moins parler de nicolas sarkozy et de
parler davantage d'europe en convoquant
tous ces ténors tout de suite le
reportage signé sighor ibanez
boulevard du temple à paris hier soir
1700 spectateurs se pressent sous le
chapiteau du cirque d'hiver premier
meeting du ps pour soutenir la liste en
ile-de-france mot d'ordre à l'entrée
changer l'europe
je veux qu'ils aient des lois sociales
je veux qu'on protège les gens qui en
ont besoin
c'est très important pour moi si on a
une majorité de gauche
on pourra faire des pressions pour
affaires d je pense qu'on pourra lutter
beaucoup plus efficacement que si on est
minoritaire et si on garde monsieur
barroso sur la scène les grandes figures
franciliennes ont été réquisitionnés
pour l'occasion
ovation pour le maire de paris bertrand
delanoë mais aussi pour le très
populaire robert badinter besoin de
renfort car la campagne socialiste ne
décolle pas cinq points derrière l'ump
dans les sondages alors il faut cogner
fort contre une droite déjà bien
installé au parlement européen il parle
de l'europe qui protège mais ils n'ont
eu de cesse de mettre en oeuvre la
constatation des travailleurs à travers
la directive bolkestein le dumping
fiscal et social
la directive temps de travail avec la
tentative de porter la limite jusqu'à 65
heures par semaine
le démantèlement des services publics
elle cela l'europe qui protège un
discours social très attendu par les
militants cette période de crise un
contexte qui ne semble pourtant pas
profité au ps prise en tenailles entre
le npa d'olivier besancenot et le modem
de françois bayrou martine aubry abat sa
dernière carte
l'appel au vote utile sans critiquer les
autres partis de gauche dit il n'ya
qu'un tour
la france et l'europe vont mal eh bien
il faut voter pour ceux qu'ils peuvent
changer l'europe car les français ne
veulent plus de cette europe libérale
prochain grand rendez vous pour les
socialistes le meeting à marseille mardi
prochain d'ici là obligations d'inverser
la tendance pour la première fois depuis
1979 en france le parti de l'opposition
risque de ne pas arriver en tête aux
européennes
alors est ce qu il est vrai que le
parton de dire que vous avez cette
semaine changer un peu de stratégie on
parle - nicolas sarkozy en parle
davantage d'europe parce que c'est
peut-être davantage payant alors j'ai eu
des bonnes choses j'ai vu les différends
reportage et permettez moi de vous dire
qu'il ya énormément ou de bêtise ou de
contrevérités je vais vous dire une
chose je reviens sur cette histoire des
sondages hollande 99
j'ose pas au mieux de sa forme on venait
de faire le rmi convenu de faire les
emplois jeunes on venait d'aborder la
question de la réduction du temps de
travail ont fait 21
regardez les sondages tel qu'il nous
nous créditent aujourd'hui cessé à un
score qui correspond à 1 correspond à
cela après je vous le dis actuellement
lorsque l'on voit ce qui est en train
d'arriver à droite où il ya qu une seule
liste favorable au président de la
république moins de 30% nous l'avait
déjà expliqué je tiens à insister parce
que l'amour devez vous me donnez
appareil vous sûrs mais des deux
reportages qui reviennent d'une manière
incroyable sur des choses qui ne
correspondent pas aux chiffres il suffit
d'un vos téléspectateurs d'aller sur le
site du ministère de l'intérieur a gardé
les résultats au cours de ces dernières
élections européennes depuis 77 jours
il peut de zircon stratégie il n'y a pas
de changement de stratégie
il ya différents temps de la campagne
nous avons décidé nous qui avions
désigné
nous candidats en premier qui avions
pour la première fois un texte de tous
les partis européens qui avions un texte
des socialistes français qui est un bon
contenu de dire dans un premier temps on
place les français devant la situation
qu'ils connaissent en france
dans un deuxième temps on mobilise nos
élus et dans un troisième temps ne passe
aux propositions il était impossible et
propose bien sûr et je vais revenir dans
l'opinion publique vous imaginez ce que
nous aurions entendu si d'un seul coup
alors que l'on connaît une crise
économique et sociale sans précédent
l'on aurait parler que d'europe sans
parler de la situation française
après pour l'europe maintenant il est
temps de dire voilà il y a une majorité
de droite au parlement
et ça ne peut pas durer parce qu'on a vu
que cette majorité a été silencieuse que
barroso a été inaudible en période de
crise et qu'il est temps de dire voilà
maintenant très vite si les socialistes
qui sont les seuls à pouvoir représenter
majorité alternative au parlement
européen sont majoritaires on engagera
tout de suite 100 milliards d'euros pour
avoir un véritable plan anti crise anti
européen nous créerons
10 millions d'emplois notamment dans
toute l'économie verte parce que l'on
voit les besoins qui existent en terme
de logement de transport d'environnement
et nous installerons un véritable
bouclier européen de protection pour
lutter contre les délocalisations
il ya installé un salaire minimum
européen un salaire minimum de
convergence des des critères sociaux de
convergence pour éviter comme on l'a vu
dans le conflit continental de donner
l'impression aux français et aux
européens qu'ils sont jouer les uns
contre les autres en fonction de leur
niveau d'impôt sur les sociétés de leur
protection sociale et de leurs salaires
et c'est ça une campagne dynamique il
faut plusieurs temps si l'on devait
donner à monsieur oui mais regardez ces
propositions mais les autres sont dans
la même situation je vous rappelle et ça
a été dit dans un de vos reportages
voilà à peine quelques jours que la
droite à ses listes complètes air et je
crois que ça aussi les électeurs vont
lentement
parmi les partis qui font du tort au ps
europe écologie avec les principales
têtes de listes eva joly daniel cohn
bendit ee yannick jadot qui donnait un
meeting à or c'est mercredi au programme
la morale des grands patrons l'histoire
de l'europe ou encore la nécessité pour
les vingt-sept d'avoir une politique
étrangère commune des images signées est
gérée jérémy hartmann claude bartolone
est ce qu'il vous manque au ps un daniel
cohn bendit pour incarner cette campagne
ans par je ne crois pas je pense que
nous avons nous des daniel cohn bendit
quand est ce que c'est vous prenez sa
masse qu'il faut pas un leader
charismatique à leurs lacunes aux une
belle question c'est que moi je suis
totalement opposé à ce mode de scrutin
malheureusement on a aussi des
responsabilités dans le cadre de la
régionalisation du scrutin européen
alors que c'est totalement absurde
on ne demande pas un parlementaire
européen d'être sur les marchés ou
d'avoir un lien quotidien avec ses
électeurs
il doit être au parlement européen et
moi je regrette le temps où il y avait
une tête de liste qui incarnait une
politique européenne
mais pour le reste vous savez lorsque je
vois la qualité de vincent peillon
lorsque je vois les talents le talent
d'harlem désir lorsque l'on connaît la
détermination européenne d'henri weber
lorsqu'on connaît les capacités de
trautmann franchement vous pouvez les
prendre tous gerber 30 mals valent bien
un cohn bendit sinon je pense que c'est
cohn bendit puissance 4 parce que xala
où les verts en ont un nous on en a et
tous est de qualité dans chaque salle a
dû refaire combien final c'est quoi
votre bois je peux le plus le score le
plus élevé possible mais est bien
au-dessus de la moyenne de des résultats
qui ont été les nôtres depuis 79 c'est
en fonction de cela que l'on examinera
les résultats
indécrottable vous savez moi je pense
que pour les socialistes le plus grand
danger ce ne sont pas les autres partis
de gauche c'est l'abstention si hélas
nos compatriotes devait se dire l'europe
ne sert à rien et ça ne vaut pas le coup
de se déplacer là nous connaîtrons tous
des difficultés à les en attendant on va
passer à la journée de jeudi françois
fillon jour les madame soleil de
l'économie française
jeudi matin grande interview du premier
ministre dans le journal le figaro
l'occasion pour lui de faire passer deux
messages
évidemment la situation économique est
toujours critique mais l'embellie se
précise et dans tous les cas de figure
pas de changement de cap pour la
politique fiscale tout de suite le
détail sur ces annonces avec mathilde
terrier premiers engagements pris par
françois fillon les impôts
n'augmenteront pas pour combler le
déficit public
un déficit dont le premier ministre
annonce qu'il devrait doubler cette
année à cause du plan de relance et du
manque à gagner fiscal pour réduire les
dépenses françois fillon prévoit 34
mille suppressions de postes dans la
fonction publique
pour cela un départ en retraite sur deux
ne sera pas remplacé
d'ailleurs concernant le marché de
l'emploi françois fillon prévient qu'il
continuera à se dégrader jusqu'à cet été
autre annonce faite par le chef du
gouvernement une reprise économique
lente en europe dès 2010
il précise toutefois que personne ne
reviendra à l'équilibré en 2012
enfin quant à la désignation de
christine lagarde en tant que
commissaire européen
françois fillon affirme son souhait
qu'elle reste ministre de l'économie
claude bartolone que le gouvernement
maintienne son refus d'augmenter les
impôts c'est une belle preuve de
constance où c'est une grande erreur
politique
je pense que c'est de l'irresponsabilité
on a vu ce qu'a pu être les résultats
d'un premier ministre qui était droit
dans ses bottes
en voilà un qui est droit dans le figaro
mais je pense que ça peut avoir des
conséquences c'est la première fois
qu'on a le premier mix qui dirait rien
avant 2011 en termes de sortie de crise
et vous pensez que si il devait avoir
comme seul discours maintenant rien
avant 2011
on ne touche à rien et on négocie pas il
ne risque pas d'y avoir de mouvement
dans le pays je pense qu'il prend de
très grands risques avec la situation
sociale du pays
alors justement jeudi les médecins et
personnels les hôpitaux sont dans la rue
pour protester contre le projet de loi
bachelot entre 9 et 25 mille personnes
gst dans une trentaine de villes pour
réclamer le retrait du texte
pendant ce temps les sénateurs sont au
chevet de ce texte sur un fond de
guéguerre avec l'assemblée nationale les
députés réclament une levée de l'est de
l'urgence pour avoir une nouvelle
lecture
l'elysée a refusé jeudi toujours cela
fait maintenant huit semaines que les
facs de france sont bloqués nouvelle
journée de mobilisation notamment dans
les rues parisiennes le gouvernement
continue de dire que les examens auront
lieu que les diplômes
elles ne seront pas bradés mais les
motifs de tensions sont toujours là très
brièvement que le bartolone comment on
sort de ce type de blocage et que doit
faire le parti socialiste quelle est sa
responsabilité dans cette année nous
avons comme responsabilité de faire des
propositions c'est ce qui est en train
d'être préparée par le parti socialiste
parce que l'on voit bien que l'on ne
peut pas rester dans cette situation où
la réforme telle qu'elle est proposée
par le gouvernement est ressenti un
comme une inégalité de plus entre fadq
riche et fac pauvres comme une mise en
danger parce que soumise aux décisions
du simple président de fac et comme une
difficulté pour les enseignants
chercheurs qui se verrait en fonction de
la volonté du président devoir être
imposées ou en or de recherche ou en
heures d'enseignement et quand on sait
ce que cela pourrait représenter pour
des facs qui n'ont pas les moyens
c'est ce sont les enseignants et ce sont
les étudiants qui pourrait être mis en
difficulté moi je pense que maintenant
il faut que le gouvernement retiennent
les propositions de médiation qui ont
été faites pour que cette année ne sont
pas une année perdue notamment pour les
étudiants les plus modestes qui n'ont
pas les moyens de sacrifier une année
allez on avance il se présente comme
l'opposant le plus vigoureux à nicolas
sarkozy françois bayrou s'installe dans
le rôle de recours entre un ps qu'il
présente comme usé et un président qu'il
décrit en proie aux dérives
pour mieux comprendre la stratégie new
look du modem nous avons suivi deux de
ses candidats
jean françois kahn tête de liste dans le
grand est et sylvie goulard dans le
grand ouest à la régie
c'est une première pour ces candidats
issus de la société civile pourtant tout
sépare ces deux têtes de liste jean
françois khan 70 ans ancien patron de
presse n'a pas la carte du modem
vie goulard 44 ans ancien conseiller
politique à la commission européenne
est-elle encartés et à la question
qu'est ce qu'un bon candidat ils
soulignent leur façon de mener campagne
le bon candidat serait quelqu'un qui
arrive à dire comme raymond barre ou mad
et france ou d'autres d'ailleurs où
jaurès un autre temps pouvoir dire
vraiment ce qu'il pense c'est ta vérité
réellement sans tricher sans mentir sans
démagogie et quand même être élu ça fait
deux mois que nous sommes sur le terrain
que nous privilégions les rencontres en
petit comité avec des professionnels
notamment avec des associations parce
qu'il ya un tel besoin de rapprocher
l'europe du terrain que moi si j'ai
choisi de venir écouter les gens de
cette région déjà 60 meeting au compteur
de jean françois kahn l'homme continue
de labourer le terrain à longwy en
meurthe et moselle il constate la
mutation industrielle de la lorraine
visite une fabrique des mots et répond
aux questions d'une radio associative
alors une petite sieste est la bienvenue
avant de remonter sur scène car jean
françois kahn est avant tout un tribun
aujourd'hui si on veut que l'europe se
faire de nouveau il faut que ça le
ferment à travers à nouveau modèle est
un nouvel humanisme de notre temps c'est
à dire d'une alternative de société qui
remettent enfin l'homme dans toutes ses
dimensions
au centre du système à 720 kilomètres de
là sylvie goulard écoute et prend des
notes dans les deux sèvres elle parle
d'abeilles et de biodiversité et montent
au créneau pour parler d'europe
dans les cinq dernières années le
parlement européen a pris une directive
qui s'appelle reach pour inverser la
charge de la preuve
un fabricant de produits qui ne fait pas
la preuve que son produit n'a pas
d'incidence ne peut pas le mettre sur le
marché
sylvie goulard mène sa campagne a pas de
charge visite d'une usine de pommes et
discussions avec des industriels au
sujet du prix du lait les à ces deux
candidats ne leur parlez pas
d'absentéisme
il jure la main sur le coeur qu'ils
seront bien présents à bruxelles pour
porter leurs idées pour réformer le
système financier international pour
lutter contre l'emploi le chômage pour
relancer l'emploi pour relancer la
croissance mais attendez c'est pas deux
mesures c'est pas trois mesures c'est un
ensemble extrêmement riche extrêmement
complet cette crise n'a pas été géré de
manière européenne
on a juxtaposé des plans nationaux on
n'a pas tenté de se dire tiens c'est le
moment
faire une industrie automobile
européenne ensemble un exemple très
concret rendez vous est pris au 7 juin
prochain pour voir si la fougue de ces
deux candidats modem fait gagner des
électeurs et des sièges pour le
parlement européen
claude bartolone vous avez fait beaucoup
campagne contre nicolas sarkozy
finalement quelle est la bonne parade
face au modem c'est d'abord que les
socialistes soient eux-mêmes et qu'ils
parlent à leurs électeurs qu'ils fassent
des propositions sur le plan écrit sur
les universités les hôpitaux l'europe et
vous verrez que très vite on se
constatera une nouvelle fois l'écart
qu'il ya entre le temps que l'on
consacre au modem et ses résultats
souvenez-vous au brand des dernières
élections municipales c'était bayrou
superstar et même à pau il a été battu
500 livres est là sous voie vous l'avez
vu ce livre est ce que vous êtes
pleinement en accord avec lui nous je
les ai pas lues pourquoi parce qu'on
voit bien qu'ils essaient de bâtir toute
sa stratégie sur une position anti
sarkozy mais pour moi ça ne suffit pas
parce que la prochaine élection
présidentielle ne sera pas gagnée dans
l'antisarkozysme elle sera gagnée sur un
thème le projet il faut que les français
puissent se dire au moment de la
prochaine élection présidentielle comme
c'est le cas pour le lait l'élection
européenne
quel est le projet qui nous est présenté
et qu'est ce que ça peut nous amener
comme changement dans notre existence
or actuellement il sarkozy a il est
aussi anti ps il propose d'ailleurs un
vieux électeurs de voter pour lui à
changer quelle est sa technique sa
technique son seul paris c'est de dire
voilà au moment de l'élection
présidentielle parce qu'il n'y a que ça
qui l'intéressent
je vais réussir à démontrer que la
droite dure représentée par sarkozy a
échoué et que les socialistes divisés ne
peuvent pas être au second tour donc je
serai au second tour et du coup la
droite modérée votera pour moi et les
socialistes me préféreront à sarkozy et
c'est cela qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit
c'est pour ça que je le dis à hollande
ya bon nombre d'autres ne parlons pas de
bayrou c'est pas notre problème
on verra une fois que nous aurons
rassembler les socialistes rassembler la
gauche que feront les républicains qui
nous préfèrent à sarkozy au monde
l'élection présidentielle mais pour le
moment ça ne suffit pas d'être anti
sarkozy moi je ne passerai un accord
électoral qu'avec ceux qui partagent les
mêmes valeurs et le même projet et pour
le monde comme il
le projet ses divisions m quand on veut
arrêter de parler françois bayrou on va
garder du temps pour la journée de
vendredi et des députés toujours à la
recherche d'un compromis pour leur
nouveau règlement alors c'est un sujet
un peu technique mais qui passionne bien
sûr les parlementaires la nouvelle
organisation de leurs travaux toute la
semaine gauche et droite ont essayé de
s'entendre sur des règles communes avec
au final une certaine bonne volonté de
part et d'autre et un certain nombre de
compromis sauf que les sujets qui
fâchent reste encore à examiner germes
andrieu dès la reprise du débat mardi
dernier le climat est électrique tout
dialogue semble impossible entre la
majorité et l'opposition
le préalable il est simple si vous
voulez qu'on puisse débat bien longue et
pour aller vers ce compromis
c'est-à-dire ce consensus
alors il faut qu'on revienne aux textes
de la revue la résolution du président
accoyer mais je ne me fais pour autant
aucune illusion
ça ne sera jamais assez votre réflexe de
préambule en est une nouvelle
illustration et jeudi dans tous les cas
de figure nous aurons passé ce règlement
chaque groupe campe sur ses positions
alors pour sortir de cette impasse
bernard acoyer décide de se rendre en
personne à matignon pour défendre sa
réforme du règlement
la résolution que j'ai préparé est une
résolution équilibrée aux modernisations
assemblée
répondant aux modifications
constitutionnelles elle n'est ni de
droite ni de gauche
elle n'est ni pour ni contre la majorité
ou l'opposition
c'est un texte d'application qui n'a
aucun esprit partisan
accusé par l'opposition de mettre en
place son règlement jean françois copé
joue la carte de l'apaisement et propose
de faire des concessions
mercredi soir l'opposition semblent
rassurés plusieurs accords sont trouvés
pour lutter contre l'absentéisme ou pour
renforcer le rôle de l'opposition dans
le cadre du contrôle parlementaire
la voie du compromis se confirmait hier
soir avec l'accord de la majorité pour
reporter les articles sur le temps
global
à la fin du texte pourtant cette
disposition fondamentale n'a toujours
pas trouvé de consensus
il faudra bien trancher il nous reste
encore monsieur le président une bonne
partie du travail à faire et nous savons
bien que au coeur de du débat sur ce
règlement va reste reste la question du
temps législatif programmé
bernard acoyer jean françois copé
dispose d'une semaine pour trouver un
compromis
la reprise des débats sur la disposition
de temps global ne reprendra que le 26
mai expliqué à ceux qui nous regardent
pour quoi ce nouveau règlement de
l'assemblée il cristallise à ce point
toutes les tensions du moment
parce que en germe il y à
l'amoindrissement de la voix de
l'opposition
et on le voit bien dans votre sujet on
vient d'évoquer la semaine qui va rester
à copé accoyer pour se mettre d'accord
et c'est ça qui est insupportable c'est
que l'on voit actuellement le rôle joué
par le président du groupe ump pour en
gros être la seule voie tu comptes à
l'assemblée nationale comme si le débat
démocratique dans le pays n'étaient que
la discussion du président la république
du gouvernement avec le président du
groupe a mis les arbitres
je ne crois pas que ce soit de la
responsabilité du président de
l'assemblée nationale d'aller voir le
premier ministre pour discuter du
règlement intérieur de l'assemblée
nationale mais on est chez les fous
c'est théoriquement la séparation entre
l'exécutif le législatif
nous avons déjà dit nous ce que nous
pensions même de la venue du président
de la république devant le parlement
alors maintenant aller demander au
gouvernement ce qui est bon pour
l'assemblée non franchement il ya
quelque chose qui ne fonctionne pas au
sein de l'assemblée actuellement et on
va bien avec la fureur qui vous anime ce
que seront
les travaux de la semaine prochaine on
voit bien que cette affaire
effectivement et loire d'être terminée
en tout cas cette édition elle se
termine merci beaucoup claude bartolone
d'avoir été notre invité marc sicard
volume à merci à vous il nous reste plus
qu'à vous souhaiter une très bonne
semaine sur les chaînes parlementaires
à bientôt
avec matthieu pigasse un banquier pour
le moins atypique
nous tenterons de comprendre comment
l'impensable est arrivé à l'automne 2008
que reydel en vérité la crise brutale
qui agite l'économie mondiale comment
penser ce monde en crise pour que demain
ne soit pas pire encore c'est tout de
suite dans le temps de penser
l'europe va bientôt voter pour se
choisir un avenir en mai lcp assemblée
nationale visite les enjeux de cette
élection magazine reportages émissions
spéciales l'union des 27 sera notre
invité vedette au programme également
des documentaires pour comprendre le
défi économique et politique jeune john
robb venant de l'identité culturelle et
religieuse
pour être clair la couronne de douze
étoiles sur le bleu du ciel occidentale
et celle de la vierge
les solutions concrètes pour un
développement durable
l'agrotourisme c'est en gros la
prolongation de l'activité agricole par
le tourisme l'europe dans tous ses états
l'europe dans tous ces débats c'est en
mai sur la chaîne parlementaire
assemblée nationale
c'est dans sa chambre